hello and welcome to the game highlights
for the third game in the google
deepmind challenge match I'm Chris
Garlock with the American duty journal
joined by Michael Redmond nine Don
professional this was the key match
although actually every match has been
key but this one particularly so because
Lisa doll had his back to the wall he
was down 2-0 needed one win to keep his
hopes alive and that didn't happen right
but we're going to take a look he had a
heck of a game and let's take a look and
see what happened in the the game yeah
this was a very exciting game with a lot
of fighting and I think Lee said oh he
played a fighting opening really and
played true to his style and actually
played some very powerful fighting in
the game so I think it would be very
difficult for most players to beat him
went the way he played today as with the
other two matches it was incredibly
entertaining mm-hmm yeah and right here
we see black playing the height Chinese
Zeki which is a bit unusual nowadays but
it is a sickie an opening in which Lisa
doll can show his power so it's I think
it's even more than much more than the
first two games actually it's sort of
true to the way that Lee SEDOL likes to
play and the opening that in which he
will be a formidable player and he had
done an all-nighter not not last night
but the night before we had the day off
yesterday stayed up until 6:00 a.m.
going over it with I think four or five
other top every threesome they were top
pros Yeah right well it's good that he
didn't do it last night
and it's a kind of a natural thing to
really go into this kind of intense
study over night after a loss loss like
that because it's it's going to be
pretty hard to sleep anyway because
you're going to be all hyped up and also
the fact that you're trying your mind
will be keep snapping back into the game
right and keeping trying you keep trying
to find find out why you lost right so
we have to completely go through that
and find your mistakes and then
sometimes you're satisfied to the point
that you can go to sleep but there is a
point in there it is going to it all
night and trying to find some weaknesses
maybe enough ago I don't think you did
so in this game black is playing a moil
that might be part of the plan it also
sort of works with Lisa doles go so I
think there's nothing wrong with what
he's doing here
okay this move that white played alphago
it's not unheard of it's maybe a bit
unusual for white to be playing this
because white sort of inviting black
tune invade somewhere around here and
make trouble with but since white does
have these two stones in the background
the fight here is going to be vital for
white so why it's sort of inviting black
in and asking black to start a fight
which is that's the part that's unusual
for white to be doing this but the local
fight will be an advantage for white
because white does have these two stones
to back up wide area now it's about time
for white to jump into blacks moil some
players very few actually but some
players would be continuing to build up
White's MO and letting black to build
blacks mob generally just because of the
one move difference black playing first
black spoil his territorial framework
tends to be bigger and quite often if
the players play the same number of
moves on the sides then the final move
for black will be somewhere in the
center of the board and that rule will
really make blacks framework much much
bigger than whites so this is a good
time for white to sort of break that
pattern and jump into the moil so I
played a soos base jump at this point
the normal way to continue attacking
white would be to play something like
this and maybe a kosumi for white to
this way sure and then here black is
taking territory along the side white is
still not safe white would continue with
something like this
and then there would be a lot of
variations but you can see the black is
taking territory while threatening white
and then after maybe at this point or
maybe after a while black would be
switching to the lower side or the right
side this would be a more conventional
way for black to continue the move that
black did play this move here is a very
aggressive move it's actually a sort of
a scary way for black to be playing
because when white does as white did in
the game that close to me there this
this white is just playing to make life
for this group and it's sort of going to
scoop out all the black territory in the
immediate area and so black has to get a
good attack going otherwise that a
normal kind of an attack will not be
good enough to make up for the sacrifice
that black is making in the territory on
the sides here and both sides will be
sort of disappearing as we will see as
the moves can continue do you think that
Lisa doll a plan to just go ahead and
fight you know his style from right well
I think he could have easily played the
kosumi instead but the attachment here
to divide white into two and try to get
a decisive attack it's sort of true to
his style okay it might have been it's a
it's sometimes considered an over play
because the cornerstones are not all
that strong and why can use that to
reinforce the white group so most
players would hesitate to do that but I
think if Lisa doll did that against most
pros he would be able to make it work
and so it's pretty impressive that it
didn't work in this game it shows how
strong alphago is yes that's right and
now the corner is a bit weak so black
added one move to the corner and that
sort of stops white from playing
something on this side layer two so
white moves out yes black pushes and
covering here is a good shape well it's
sort of a natural shape in any pro twos
actually because extending here and
black and play here allowing white shape
to fall apart like this would be very
bad for white it wouldn't be very bad
shape and it would be just too heavy
so this is natural it plays this
exchange before jumping out so this is a
very nice a natural sequence it's not
really anything special but it's just a
sequence of good moves that really have
a nice kind of feeling to them when we
were reviewing this you just you really
like this entire 20 30 move sequence
coming out of that she kept saying it
was beautiful
well why just playing sort of very
natural looking moves there's nothing no
extra it's not as if white is sort of
muscling up and trying to do something
special White's just playing what what
look like normal moves and in the
process is sort of refuting black like
if black plays something like this then
why it's going to get out in the center
and these these stones are beginning to
look like they are having no problem
there they're beginning to look like a
strong group and so it's a very smooth
way for white to sort of move out into
the center black continued to attack
with this and here yes this move right
that's right I love this that move is
it's already looking like it could be
sort of like a winning move because it
it's much more effective than the slower
moves like this or somewhere around here
it's much more effective when black
plays a defensive move like this and
white can play something on the outside
getting a great sequence of moves on the
outside and just punishing black here
while black has to play another move to
actually connect them on the side yeah
black would have to put another line in
there
so black counter-attacks white pushes
and again oh sorry that's me
yeah and again going directly against
the black group would be a bit dangerous
so blacks white sliding here is another
nice move yeah at this point we're just
talking about really good moves it's not
as if human players don't play moves
like this too but the whole sequence
here is sort of leading to that and it's
it's the sort of effortless way that
alphago is setting up this good position
and the game is already looking good for
white so basically where did black go
wrong I only move that I can find that I
don't like is the
the original attachment move so the
necessity of taking it back so far is
just sort of illustrating how strong
alphago is right because one mistake
early in the game usually doesn't have
that effect and so the way it can punish
that with such normal looking moves
which that's really the hallmark of a
very strong player wide escapes and now
black has all these stones that are not
really very well connected so that's why
black has to play a number of very slow
moves here just to connect its group
white connects and black connects and
you can see black is being forced to
play sort of dumb it points useless
points just to save it stones and then
white jumped here here and why connected
once and this is still a very
complicated fight like this white group
here and maybe in that area if we
combine those two that white has a
potential to make one eye maybe but
that's a potential one eye white needs
one eye elsewhere so basically white
cannot afford to be surrounded here
black also has a weak group here so it's
really and black has a weak group here
because of the white stones that are
friendly for white in the area this is
already looking like a very difficult
fight for black here and here and here
no point jumps and with this exchange
this group is cut off from this group
this white group is still not settled
really this white group is not settled
but on a whole we see that the black
groups seem to be weaker than the white
groups in general so I think that this
looks like it's a fight that is
advantageous for white mm-hmm black
plays here this is threatening to
connect underneath basically at this
point I laid a move white played a move
that I thought was a bit slack that's
this one yes I would have been tempted
just to keep on attacking black right
and these three stones are really so so
weak
I think that white could have helped it
to kind of done it this way there is a
lot of danger just because there are so
many weak groups floating around if
black can find some way to play some
forcing moves against this white group
and maybe close this in it looks a bit
unlikely doesn't it but I think that
when alphago plays a move like this that
looks a bit slack it actually means that
alphago has already assessed the
position and decided that White's ahead
or alphago is ahead that is in this case
it's white and that alphago can afford
to let black off the hook just a little
bit because alphago already has control
of the game I wonder if this is
something that we can learn from alphago
already is that by doing that
simplifying the game I mean obviously
has a much more stronger look ahead and
so forth well I think that actually
after I think people can make the
judgment like professionals and make the
judgement that this is looking good for
white okay but I think that I would have
trouble saying that this is the safer
course to victory see because it takes
even in this case it takes a lot of
doing to take this all the way to win we
saw all sorts of complicated stuff at
the end we did yes we did and that kind
of stuff will happen and so in some ways
if white can win the immediate fight
here after playing this move then it
will be a quick end and much more easy
for white - less stressful less time but
of course
alphago doesn't mind about an issue so a
white plays here black plays once here
to make a weakness in white school
white has to answer here and then black
connects underneath so black is white
push through once black is sort of being
let off the hook here because these
stones are connected if black plays one
more move say for instance here then
these stones will have a live shape so
black white jumps here let's just do a
few more
like this my pushes at this point black
is a life with one more move white stone
still do not do not have eyes so white
had black does have some potential
attack
ideally black should be able to use that
attack to sort of break open the side
here in which case it seems black might
have a chance but actually since blacks
territories on the whole are pretty
small I think actually it's already
looking good for alphago the game goes
on for quite a while we encourage you to
look at the the full stream on the web
to get all the details but I think first
of all thank you Michael for a great
commentary and congratulations to
alphago and the entire deepmind team for
a great win there are two more rounds to
go and I'm sure that Lisa Doyle will be
continuing to bring his a-game and we
will be there as well so thanks again
thank you